final start for chad cool
this 2020 season after missing last year
recovering from tommy john surgery
like trevor williams last night stephen
brought before him wanting to finish on
a high note and
anthony rizzo will be the lead off
hitter and it's slammed
to right by rizzo but right at polanco
so one
out one pitch can't do much more than
that i mean that's uh
good as you can do who cares how hard it
was throw it in there one pitch one out
alec mills spectacled 28 year old from
clarksville tennessee who pitched
a no-hitter two starts back
last time out he suffered a loss
no score bottom of the first and the
batter is colin moran
the swing of the fly ball hit out to
deep center field maven back warning
track leaps there it goes
home run for colin moran and one to the
left of center
his ninth home run of the year and the
pirates
they got a high fast ball and hit the
ball very high
and it just kept carrying the ball at
the top of the strike zone maybe not
even a strike it was that
that high reynolds had a big three run
homer off alec mills back in early
september
there's a swinging fly ball out toward
right center
maven and here and this one just keeps
going it's gone that ball just kept on
going out of here in the first row
brian reynolds with home run number six
and the pirates
so moran homers with two outs in the
first and now reynolds
seconds after polanco is thrown out at
second base hits the home run
to give the pirates a two-nothing lead
two-nothing pirates lead on a pair of
home runs
frazier bounced out back in the first
swing of the deep fly ball out to right
he sends this one out of here
and that one hits the second the last
row of seats in right
adam frazier is homered for the second
straight game and the pirates
lead on three long balls three to
nothing frazier with that short
quick stroke and uh he's one of those
guys where it seems like when
he hits one out there's a couple more to
follow rizzo to third hayward
to second here's cameron maben i'll
swing it a liner towards center field
and that is going to be caught by
reynolds to
end the inning they maven hit it sharply
but right to
the center fielder and the cubs walk
away empty-handed
reynolds at third and riddle at second
frazier homer last inning
and he homered yesterday as well and the
other way in a base hit for frazier
this will score one this will score
just one as the out is recorded on a
heck of a play there by schwerberg and
carratini that gives the pirates a
four-nothing lead
jason kiddness at the plate for the cubs
jack cool delivers there's a swing of
the miss kepness down at strikes
and he strikes out swinging is gone two
outs there's a cut and a miss
and cool strikes out the side in the
fifth inning cubs still without a hit
through five
here's bell facing the left-handed ryan
as a line drive to left field toward the
wall
and it is gone a line drive home run for
bell
he hit a line drive just over the wall
down the line
for a two run homer and the pirates with
a long ball
one away here's anthony rizzo rizzo in
the air
high and deep and off the wall
cubs have their first hit it's a double
just missed his third homer in his many
days
and so keepness in scoring position with
one out here's javier baez
and it came in a clipton hit by pitch
and baez
takes umbrage yelling you can tell the
way he reacted he thought there was some
intent or clearly took umbrage bill
welke is just
he doesn't want any issues so he's going
to warn both teams just to eliminate any
of the problems now polanco
with a big hit here could take over the
team leading rbi oh yeah
here to left plenty deep for another run
schwarber will make the catch the runner
at third hayes will tag and a
sacrifice fly makes it seven nothing
nice job by uh not trying to pull that
ball
and they're set up on that side for a
double play looking for a ground ball
blanco knows if he goes to left it's
much easier to get the ball into the
outfield
take a look at ceilings numbers brought
to you by shili's
just a couple innings of work so far
hard thrower
seen him hit a hundred miles an hour a
couple of times in those two innings
cedarlin takes care of hamilton
flanking savages this ball's popped up
this should do it
and it is raise the jolly rogers adam
frazier picks up the baseball
and the pirates pick up another win
that's three in a row a shutout
of the chicago guns